never compete on price if you want to
build a successful business if you want
to attract ideal clients if you want to
make the money that you deserve to make
and build a massively successful company
that you can be proud of the answer does
not come by competing on price you have
to find another way to stand up a way
for people to recognize your expertise
and pay you what you're worth I've got a
question from a reader Charles on
facebook wrote in to say he started this
event management company and has been
going well he's been marketing promoting
trying to get this thing off the ground
is not getting any traction and I asked
him what makes you different from all
the other companies doing the same thing
because he's in a competitive market
whatever you're selling you have big
competition as well we're all in
competitive markets so you have to find
a way to stand out so I said Charles how
do you stand out what's different about
your business any rights in this a price
what I do is offer the same product at a
cheaper rate to my prospects it's not
going to work competing on price is a
recipe for failure you have to find
something else to separate yourself from
your competition what is missing in this
business you said so he wrote he's been
working in this business for six years
as an employee now he just started his
own company what do you want to change
about the business what do you want to
change about the industry what's broken
how can you offer more value than your
competition that's where your focus
needs to be that's not how can I offer
the same for a slightly cheaper price
it's what can we do that's totally
different what is our competition doing
that's wrong and in almost every
industry this massive opportunities to
stand out most of your competition is
doing the same thing their average
companies they're not memorable nobody's
talking about them you have a chance to
really stand up and stand out
but you've got to come up with what is
going to make you different what
problems do you solve that nobody else
is done before and start pushing that
message you're going to start seeing
results I know it's hard to do something
different I know it's hard to think
outside the box I know it's how we've
been trained to do something a certain
way for years to then break that and say
I'm going to go in this new direction
but you have to do that if you try to do
what everybody else is doing you're not
going to have success you've got to
build beyond you've got to put something
unique in here so there's a couple ways
to do it the first I would look at your
past experience you've worked six years
in that industry look at your experience
in that business and try to find
something that's missing when you talk
to clients when they ask you to do
things for them what were some of the
things that your company couldn't do or
that charge too much for or that didn't
quite have the value that they need it
what were those things number 2 i'd
start going out and talking to prospects
talking to companies and just asking
them what do you need out of an event
management company what are some of the
problems you're facing just talk and
listen don't go and sell them anything
just talk to them and listen and they
will tell you things that you never
thought of then you can build into your
business that could be the hallmark of
what your whole company is built around
and number three I try to inject more of
yourself into your business what are you
staying for what do you believe in what
do you like doing what are your values
and inject that into the into the
company so for example if reliability is
your thing you know you are always
reliable you're always on time you
always get everything done as a customer
wanted ahead of schedule that's your
thing that's your mantra and you hate it
when people are not on time they don't
deliver push that let customers know you
are the company that is
always reliable reliability is your
thing and you're going to attract
companies who value reliability who pay
you more for reliability you'll attract
employees who like reliability or track
suppliers investors all sorts of people
who enjoy and love the reliability value
you put that front and center and you've
changed the landscape you're now not
just an event management company but you
stand for something you have a value
system that's different than everybody
else and you'll get better customers so
what is the word for you and maybe it's
not reliability is something else but
bring yourself and your personal beliefs
into your business you have a lot more
success you have a lot more fun you make
a lot more money believe so those are
you watching you liked the video thumbs
up below thank you so much i love seeing
those come in and i want to hear what
you have to think please leave a comment
underneath it makes you want to do more
and i want to answer your questions so
leave in the comment section below truly
it makes my morning every day we reading
through your youtube video comments it
really impacts me so please leave those
comments thank you and I'll see you soon